I was on the plane coming back dude I
was on the plane coming back from what
do you call it where you know what
wherever the [ __ ] I was hey man look if
you're a guy were a girl that talks too
loud on the plane
you deserve to not eat for three days or
now you deserve to not eat the whole day
three days is a lot when you're on the
plane straight up shut the [ __ ] up shut
the [ __ ] up people are on the plane just
like well you know I talked to I talked
to him the other day and you know it's
all you know he said he'd have the
reports in and you know he didn't and
it's fine but you know we'll get it and
it'll all be fine but my my issue is if
he's gonna say he's gonna do something
and he doesn't do it and everyone in the
[ __ ] cabin is just looking at each
other like check out this [ __ ]
[ __ ] or even worse it's it's a woman
even worse it's a woman because they've
got the voice that's like yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know when a woman has a [ __ ]
yeah
it's like guys for some reason guys as
annoying as [ __ ] guys will just be like
this talking like this but when women do
it it's just like me yeah and you're
like all for [ __ ] sake is a dolphin in
3f yeah so I talked to her and I and
yeah yeah I look at him dude guy or girl
I i straight-up look at him I go like
this I look at them and they're always
in like a [ __ ] button-down if you're
and with beat fly comfy [ __ ] who
in a suit you know guys relax dude yeah
so you know and this guy was in front of
me dude first of all he was 65 so you
know how to live right you've had 65
years of doing it don't you know how to
live
and he's just talking to the flight
attendant and the flight attendant is
talking back like he doesn't have a
hundred and fifty cups to fill with ice
and this guy's just yeah cuz when I
usually fly from oh dude really oh when
you usually fly you usually when you
usually fly you know how boring the
sentence begins the boring how boring
the sentence is that begins with well
when I usually fly hey
the lying is boring that's why most
people sleep during it he was doing
jokes and the flight attendant by the
way was like love in it they were the
same age so they were like it just
drives me and it doesn't mean to be
talking to you if you're talking loud
around as practiced touching your top
lip to your bottom lip practice that
30,000 feet in the air only talk 5,000
feet above sea level
5,000 feet above sea level
- sea level that's we're talking happens
if you're above 5,000 feet zip okay or
if you're on a [ __ ] tube a long
big-ass tube that's the thing people
will get at 6 o'clock in the morning
there was another girl I was flying to
wherever or no 8 Daytona that's where I
was flying to from from Sacramento and
she was just like in in LA in line
boarding and I was already sitting down
and she was me a map map map map and I
looked up dude me up map just loud
[ __ ] just just say quieter we all hear
you if you're like this why do you have
the mop mop it dude and he was [ __ ]
the guy dude and the guy was just cuz
when I win this one III the guy said I
more than [ __ ] III when I he literally
looked to the guy next to him he said
hey do you know the court pointed to his
TV and he said you know the code to get
porn on this oh Jesus Christ man you
know what dude you have to fake laugh at
it and that was just the worst I'm in
the bum behind him literally just like
this I hope he looks back so I could
just go hey dude when was your ninth
birthday cuz oh oh it already happened
oh then you know not to do this hey man
what did you just get for your ninth
birthday what do you mean what did I
just get I'm 67 oh dude my bad I thought
you just had your ninth birthday because
you're doing what you're doing what kind
of cake did you have that's what that's
what I'm gonna ask any time someone does
loud playing talking from now on I'm
gonna turn to them and I'm gonna say hey
what kind of cake did you have or hey
how was your ninth birthday and when
they look at me confused I'm gonna say
oh [ __ ] dude I'm sorry I didn't realize
you're as old as you are because you're
doing what you're doing
[Music]